First of all, I want to start by saying
that um I respect that it's your
platform and we do whatever you want to
do and um I want to be a respectful
guest on yours. However, um I listened
to your stream, the full stream last uh
Monday and um I think that I do have a
complete rebuttal for absolutely
everything that you said. And uh I think
it began with something that was a
really really huge mistake from
yourself. A very gross misreading of
Islamic scripture which is by the way
written in the original language of um
Arabic the Seemetic uh um target
audience language of the Bible is
actually um for the Israelites only. But
you guys only have the manuscripts that
were written decades later in Greek and
Latin etc etc. Um but in Islam we do
have the authentic scripture that was uh
sent down to prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him memorized by his companions
delivered by his companion man when he
was the emperor of Arabia Egypt Syria
Palestine etc. So this is just one thing
but not to take too much of your time.
Sorry. I do respect that this is
valuable time for you. So I'll get
straight into the point again. You
misread the verse saying how can God
have gone on. So
>> sorry.
>> I'm willing to go ahead and and do that
with you. Go over those issues with you
um that you feel like I was wrong in.
>> Uh let's deal with the topic first of
the day. Let's deal with at least one.
Let's let's do at least one example of
my topic today and then I'll I'll gladly
deal with the uh uh how can Allah have a
son.
>> That's totally fine. I respect that a
lot. That's fine. Let's stick to the
topic. So you mentioned child marriage
etc etc etc. And there is something
about prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
that you sort of brushed upon last time
that links to this about morality etc.
>> I have a question for go on
>> I have a question for you. Would you,
and this is just for you, like Ali, like
personally, and your morals and your
character, would you ever tell a woman
uh a woman to suckle
uh another grown man who is not her
husband or her or her child?
>> Here is the thing. I would not do that,
but this is the thing. The the hadith
you're speaking about doesn't say it
doesn't say that he has to actually go
and physically suckle from her breast.
There's no actual indication for that.
The the thing is that wet nurses when
someone gives you uh when you're a child
an infant and you have a wet nurse who
is a woman who breastfeeds you in the
place of your mother in Islam we have
this concept where your wetness is
similar to your mother. Um so basically
to uh to make this woman to make this
guy not a stranger for this woman who
basically they're in the same household
etc. And um it's just one prime example
of um it's like it's it's it's not a
legislation to keep doing it. It's
probably
>> issue.
You wouldn't tell her you wouldn't tell
her to do that.
>> So what happened? So what happened was
that she put her breast milk.
>> Before my brother, before you go on and
explaining the context, which is
perfectly fine, I just want to make sure
that you you said that you would never
tell a woman to do that. Is that right?
I would tell her to breastfeed him
through a medium. Absolutely.
>> So, so to be clear, you're saying that
you would tell a woman to breastfeed
another grown man who was not her
husband or son
>> through a medium. Yes. Which is what
happened. And that is the explanation of
all the other hadith saying that in a
pot or in a you know a sample and he
drank from it.
makes this lifts any any um this lifts
any like I can't think of the English
word for it but there's an Arabic word
that we use which is haraj which is
something like embarrassment etc etc
>> and um yeah absolutely but yeah I wanted
to tell you because you mentioned
something from last week
>> that link topic about and we're going
>> slow down slow down I want
>> I want us to address this slowly okay
>> yeah I'm sorry
>> it's okay so it says sorry So this is
Sai Muslim 1453
>> B. It says this. We're going to read the
hadith.
>> Could you cuz you said uh and I said
something I disagree with because you
said to suckle it it doesn't mean to go
ahead and and physically
>> physically suckle. So I'm going just
read this really quick. So Aisha
reported that Saleem the freed slave of
Abu Hadifa lived with him and his family
in their house. She said um Salem has
attended uh attained as men attain and
he understands what they understand and
he enters our house freely. I however
perceive that something in the heart of
Abu Hudafa whereupon Allah's apostle
said to her suckle him and you would
become unlawful for him and which Abu
Hudafa feels in his heart would
disappear. So obviously Abu David was
feeling a little uncomfortable with this
young man in his house cuz he's uh you
know he's grown and so he's not feeling
comfortable with him around the house.
So she returned and said so I suckled
him and what was there in the heart of
Abu Hufa disappeared. So she she suckled
the man and he was a grown man. If we
read the earlier hadith that says like
she responded to Muhammad like when
Muhammad said suckle him she said how
can I suckle him as he is a grown-up man
right so what does it mean to to suckle
to so basically to suckle is synonymous
here for the the the the the mechanism
that she's trying to that prophet
Muhammad peace is telling her to use to
lift the embarrassment I'm talking to
you about so if you look at the there's
by the way there's different like this
People have asked about this and there's
hadiths about Aisha's um friends and
other wives of the prophet asking about
this. Did he really suckle etc etc. Um I
don't know if I can share screen and get
the hadith but the thing is I can find
my time I can
>> I can if you if you want to do this
really quick cuz that's this is
important. I I would actually love to
see that if you have a hadith where they
go over this and ask does she really
suckle him? And then they explain what
actually went went on and what happened
because it looks pretty clear that it
says she says I went on and I suckled
him. So and we know what suckle means.
It means to you know put the breast in
the mouth. So if you're saying that
there's a hadith that explains how this
actually went about and actually she
actually put the breast milk in maybe a
cup or you know whatever it was and he
sipped from that then I would love to
see that hadith if that exists. Um it
does make sense but the thing is I do
have a little bit of a logistic issue in
trying to get it because like it's on my
phone and I'm using my uh laptop but the
thing is I do want to interject on
something you said that we know what
suckle means. The thing is that you know
what the English suck word for suckle
means, but you don't know what the
Arabic word for suk means. You don't
know what the narrations of the hadith
say in Arabic to understand it. And
again, this is like a this is a very
fundamental issue comparing Islam with
Christianity because you guys
bring Ali, I'm not bringing Christianity
into this. I'm looking at this from an
objective, you know, standpoint. If
you're saying
>> Yeah. So, if you're saying the word if
you're saying the word suckle means
something other than the obvious, like
what we obviously know what suckle
means, I'm willing to see if you could
pull up an Arabic dictionary um and and
show the wide range of the word suckle
and show that it means something else.
I'm I'm all ears. Like, I'm I'm here to
learn. So, I'm just going by from what I
know, I know what suckle means. You know
what I'm saying? So, I can't see that as
anything else you show me.
>> I understand that. But the thing is
you're a man of logic and logic dictates
here that there is a translation in from
language to language and um and the word
that basically the the hadith that he's
talking about anyway is talking about
the entire like it's it's describing the
apparatus to do something but I'm not
going to lie I mean I can't share the
screen to use here right now and I don't
even know how to type Arabic on my
keyboard anyway I can only do that on my
phone with Arabic keyboard on my laptop
I don't do I don't want to waste your
time but I can I can assert the hadith
later on my Twitter I can find these
hadith that I'm talking to you about.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, hold on. Let me
just uh if Arabic is the issue here and
you're saying that the word in the
Arabic doesn't mean to suckle, which
it's it's hard for me to believe cuz
everything that I see it says suckle,
but you're saying in in Arabic it could
be different. So, what I think that I
should do is I should Is it okay if I
bring an Is it okay if I bring an Arabic
speaker to read the hadith in Arabic?
>> It's fine.
>> Okay. So, let me see. Um,
let's see here. Let's bring up my friend
Rahm. Are you available to join my
stream? Let's see here. Um, if he's not
available, let me ask another brother.
Any Arabic speakers willing to join for
a second? All right. So, in the
meantime, right? Uh, so I I don't and to
be fair, I do not have any reason to
believe what you're saying that the word
in Arabic means something other than
suckle when every hadith narration and
every translation of the hadith, every
single one says suckle. Um, and for it
to mean something other than what suck
means, bro, I that that doesn't that
doesn't flow with me logically.
>> Okay. Okay. So, basically the word
you're saying is suck. I'm telling you
the Arabic word is which is the action
of so when the Quran says
etc etc and I know people personally
who've who've been suckled by other
women like this in this sense when
they're children so the word the the
it's like wet nurse in Arabic would be
from the word is like there's no I mean
this is not definitely saying go and
suckle it's not describing the act of
the action of suckling So is that Yeah.
Sorry. Go on.
>> Yeah. So that doesn't make sense to me,
bro. Because it looks like it's exactly
the uh it's exactly the um the action of
suckling when I mean the whole purpose
of it is to make her unlawful for
another man. So that because the law is
if you if you are suckled by the same
woman, right, then you are you're not
lawful to marry or if you've been
suckled by this woman, this woman is not
lawful for you, right? So that's
Muhammad's um Muhammad's suggestion or
not like yeah, this is it's his like,
hey, here's how you solve this issue.
Suckle him.
>> Go ahead and, you know, breastfeed him.
Breastfeed an adult and uh the problem
will be solved. your your husband won't
have an issue anymore. And it worked.
>> The thing is, I understand that you're
trying to say I I don't mean to dwell on
this too much for you. Just out of
respect for yourself, but um the the the
embarrassment is lifted by her milk. So
if he drinks from her milk, people will
know that.
>> Where does it say where does it say
that, brother, that's that's my problem
is that cuz I hear what you're trust me,
I'm not being hard-headed. I hear what
you're saying. What you're saying though
does not match the text. That's that's
the issue for me. And I'm telling you as
well with all due respect that what
you're saying as in it has to be suckle.
That is not exactly true.
>> It's not it's not me that says it has to
be suckled. Bro, that is a translation
>> that says how can I suckle him as he is
a grown man. It says to suckle him. I
didn't put this here.
>> Okay. So it's when when he says which
means to breastfeed him.
>> It literally means to breastfeed. It
does not mean to suckle. It means
breastfeed. She can feed him from her
breast and he can take what's in her
breast without suckling. So I'm telling
you the word suckle is not mentioned. It
says breastfeed.
>> The word the word means to breastfeed,
right?
>> Yep. That's true.
>> So when she's when she's suckling him or
or breastfeeding him, we we know what
that means, right, bro? Come on, man.
>> No. where we the action of breastfeeding
him which is
she can actually breastfeed him without
him doing that.
>> This is very simple but yeah look I'm
really sorry I don't mean to dwell on
this too much out of respect for
yourself. I mean I could talk about this
all day. I don't want to disrespect you
as a host who comes here and dictates
over you etc. et I'm really sorry if
this comes across. I want to be as light
as possible but like I said prophet
Muhammad peace be upon you.
>> You don't you don't have to keep
apologizing man. We're good. We're
having a good conversation. You know,
we're not going to agree, but we're
having a good conversation. You've been
respectful. You can be as truthful and
real as you as you as you want to be,
bro.
>> Okay. Okay. We don't I also want to say
we don't need to agree because you know,
even in the Quran, it says when speaking
to people of the book, when speaking, it
says
come to a common word that we worship
God only, that we do not associate
partners, that we don't take each
other's priests as mediums between us
and God, etc. So, in Islam, our job is
not to eliminate you. It's not to do
things like this. It's like
>> to what?
>> It's not to eliminate you. It's not to
like you know what
>> do you mean by eliminate?
>> So I'm saying there's there's a verse
here that is telling us eliminate as in
like get rid of you.
>> You are supposed to do that unless I
>> unless I convert and pay to Jizia. All
right. I I got a brother here. Hold on
one sec. I want to show him the hadith.
Hey Rob.
>> Hey. God bless.
>> God bless man. Can you see the screen?
>> Yeah, I can see it.
>> All right. I want you to read this.
Okay. And I want you to be as honest as
you can. Now you can see it clearly,
right? You don't you don't need me to
zoom in or anything.
>> Uh let me let me open it also from my
side.
>> Yeah. Sai Muslim 1453.
>> What's the topic?
>> Um I'll you'll you'll I I don't want to
I don't want to give it to you just yet.
I just want you to read.
>> Okay.
>> Sali Muslim 1453A.
>> Yes. It's about the adult uh thing.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So
>> So what's the question? The question is
about the word that's used for the word
suckle. To suckle.
>> Our friend here is saying that it
doesn't mean to actually suckle. It also
means to just simply breastfeed by
pouring the milk from the breast in like
some cup or something like that.
>> So I just want to know if
>> Yeah. And what is the word means? Suckle
him. Suckle him literally in the Arabic.
So and on top of that when they say
brother God logic again thank you for
having me when they say that you have to
pour the milk inside the cup what they
do not tell you is that that narration
is from
and is rejected inith.
So what they do is they use a rejected
hadith from a rejected narrator
himself who narrated who is the main
narrator in that hadith but it literally
says suck and even uh you know the wife
of Abua says but he's a grown man
>> he has a beard right so
>> exactly thank you
>> that's that's all I need to say stick
around
>> sure
>> stick around and if if you if he wants
me to prove that the hadith about the
milk inside the cup or pot is
fabricated. I can show that as well.
>> No, I don't need you to show anything
about the hadith. The fact that you
caught hadith anyway to to as a
mechanism of ours to differentiate what
is authentic from what is not and to
prove to us that the Quran has been
delivered to us without corruption,
etc., etc. That is enough. But I'm just
saying you know Arabic and you just said
that uh
means to suckle and that proves that I
don't know where you're learning Arabic
from or whatever but the action of
breastfeeding is literally breastfeed is
so this is something I'm I'm Arab and
I'm telling you is that way it's not
exactly to suckle to suckle will be a
different like you're actually doing
you're describing a motion etc. This is
the English word word. English is a 500
year old language, 600y old language,
something like this. Arabic is like what
6,000 years old or something. There are
so like the the translation here is so
gross. But your argument is coming from
a word called suckle.
>> You said the translation gross.
>> Sorry,
>> you said the translation is gross.
>> Uh gross. No, no, no. I mean gross as in
on the full scale. Gross as in grossly,
not to describe me and made a mistake.
>> Gross is holy. Sorry.
>> You're just saying that the translation
made a mistake. Is that what you're
saying?
>> I'm saying that the two languages you
are comparing virtually incomparable in
terms of like the the different the
depth of so many like the depth of so
many syllables everything and even in
terms of just the age of how long how
ancient the language is. But
>> it doesn't help. You can't you can't do
the magical Arabic game here. It doesn't
help. The word means to suckle. It
doesn't
>> English look look God logic. Look look
in English it says suckle. I'm Arab and
I'm telling you
>> and in Arabic in Arabic it say
>> no in Arabic it does not say it says
breastfeed
>> Ali how much is your knowledge about
this topic Ali because I can show you
scholars who tell you that and I will
say it as it is uh uh guys people who
know me I will say things as they are
explicitly the scholars said it's not
breastfeeding if you don't put the in
the mouth you want me to show that I can
show it else it's not called adult
breast feeding I you know I you know I
have the sources brother God lo if he
thinks that it's helping him
>> that's tough
>> and I can like I said I can show you
that what he's talking about about the
pot uh you know the milk must be poured
inside the pot or glass it's from a
fabricator whose name is Muhammad bin
Omar
and every scholar has said that he's
rejected in I mean you have no argument
and you know it
>> okay look um The thing is you said some
scholars etc. I know there's going to be
different opinions between the scholars.
That's not something I'm here to deny.
And um my point is that the word itself
suck no suckle does not mean is
breastfeed. This is the interpretation.
But let's just go the thing is um like I
said I mean you do want to move on and
discuss this because I haven't even made
the introduction to last week's sorry
last Monday's uh comment that you made
about the prophet peace be upon you.
We can we can set we can settle it here.
I appreciate you coming up, Rob, and uh
and clarifying that. Stick around
because I might need you to pull you up
again if somebody uh uses the magical
Arabic. Okay,
>> sure.
>> Um Okay. So, you're you wanted to
discuss We'll We'll uh put a pin in this
one. You wanted to discuss uh Oh, CP's
here. If CP's here, he could join, too.
You wanted to discuss uh what was it
about Allah having a son.
>> Your voice is cutting up a little bit
because of my internet, but I didn't
hear what you just said. right now.
>> You said you wanted to discuss what I
said about Allah having a son last week
or or last stream. Can you hear me? Rob,
am I coming in clear or is it just him?
>> I can hear you fine. No issue.
>> All right. So, it is Ali's uh Ali stuff.
Yeah. Everybody hit the like button. And
also everybody, this is Rob Christian.
For those of you guys who been living
under a a rock, this is Rob Christian,
man. One of the beasts, the OGs and the
beasts.
>> I mean, I'd love to discuss that. Yeah.
because there is a verse that you did uh
that there's a delay. One one second,
Ali, there there's a little delay. Um so
everybody subscribe to Rob Christian.
>> Subscribe to Rob Christian. Put his link
in the uh in the chat if you guys can
guys. Spam his link in the chat. You
guys want to subscribe to this brother
because he shows verses on the screen.
He shows sources. He breaks down the
Arabic. Can't play games with him. So
it's awesome, man. Okay. I
>> I want to say something about the God
logic. Um the thing is what I always
fascinates me is that Muslims will cry a
huge long river when we use fabricated
hadiths but when they use fabricated
hadith not even completely fabricated by
then for them it's okay to do that but
when we do it they will say no it's
fabricated they are
>> I didn't use this I use
>> let me finish. You know why? You know
you did because the one who narrates the
hadith about milk being poured inside
the pot or glass and then to drink it
not directly from the breast is a
fabricated hadith. So it doesn't help
you because if you want me to do that I
can show you that you are using it.
>> Nor
really quick guys. Nor is that
breastfeeding. The second that you take
it's it's you're not putting the breast
in the mouth. That's not breastfeeding
anymore.
>> Exactly. And that's what the scrolls
also said. By the way,
>> let let's let Ali he wanted to respond.
Go ahead Ali.
>> Yeah. So my response is the same. If he
takes from her milk regardless that is
as though he she breastfed him. So that
is the hadith. I'm not using that. I'm
not using the weak hadith is about
whatever. But again I mean the want
about it. I'm using logic. The Arabic
word is Breastfeed.
>> Breastfeed. My brother, you call
yourself God logic. Come on. The word is
breastfeed. Okay. So, it's like
>> what does that word? Look, look, Ali,
using your logic. What does And we're
using logic. Divine. Let's use God's
logic. What does breastfeeding mean?
Breastfeed. What does that mean?
>> To take from someone's milk. To be fed
by from where?
>> Where?
>> To be fed by the milk from the woman.
>> Where? What part?
Well, you know where the where the what
part OF THE WOMAN?
>> COME ON, BRO. SAY IT, BRO. LOOK,
God loic, please allow me to share my
screen if you don't mind, brother.
>> Please. So, you know, just to show that
we say something,
hold on, brother. Hold on, brother.
Brother, hold on, brother. Hold on.
Please. when we speak you know the
brother already told you when someone
like me speaks I don't speak without
backing what I say and we have the
receipts so you can you and the people
who are still confused about it can
learn that when we say something we
don't need to uh uh lie about it because
clearly you didn't do your investigation
so I'll explain to you how easy it is to
refute you watch here's
Yeah, let me let me finish, brother.
>> Where's your Where's your screen?
>> Uh, it's not showing yet.
>> Not that I see.
>> Hold on. Window
share. Does it say share? No.
>> There. There it is.
>> Uh, there you go. Look, we have the
receipts, guys. As you see on the
screen, this is a book of fatwa Q&A,
right? Islamic ruling question answer
fat.
Okay. volume two on the following page
that you see of this book. Watch this
brother got logic. So this is uh fatwa
number 199. Read with me. Answer
breastfeeding the maham. So if you
breastfeed someone he becomes your son.
Let's say is five suckling or more and
it's holding
and peep the end. You see it holding it
and put it in the mouth. That's what
breastfeeding is. And that's how you
become someone's son.
>> Mhm.
>> Uhhuh.
>> So, yeah. Again, this is this is one
hadith that you're talking about and I'm
not talking about this hadith and this
person can interpret how interpret it
however much he wants. I'm not like I'm
not going to it's not my word versus
his. It's his word versus other hadiths
of like and and it's also the the the
other.
>> Do you have any reputation, brother?
You're stuttering. Do you have any
reputation, please? What other this my
reputation is that the word does not
mean to breast to to literally go to the
breast. It means to actually take from
her milk and based on what you grow on
here fabricated hadith. Do you want me
to show you
>> what? No, I don't need the fabric. I
will show you really quick. Really
quick,
>> you just showed an interpretation by
someone you showed an external
interview.
>> You have Ali, please. you you're saying
that you have a reputation, but your
reputation has to be based on something.
Like for example, Rob, his his
reputation to you was based on the
ruling and based on what they said. What
do you have to show that what you're
saying has, you know, some substance
that it doesn't mean to put the breast
in the mouth.
>> Brother, give me give me the screen one
more time if you don't mind, brother.
Here's source number two so you can
learn. I will let him a lot and I've
been really respectful and he's asking
me.
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> So basically so basically he showed you
an exesis of the hadith that says the
hadith says it does not say to do any
beyond doesn't say from the breast milk.
So if her breast milk if he drinks her
breast milk he's fulfilled that hadith.
>> Do you have a do you have something that
says that says that you don't have to
put the nipple in the mouth? The fact
that it does not say this is enough
because all it's saying is breastfeed.
It does not say something.
>> You want me to trust You want me to
trust you? I can't trust you, man.
>> I don't want you to trust me. No, no,
no. I don't want you to trust me. It's
like, well, this is like the the people
who know both languages can decide on
this. By the way, not someone who's
apparently um apparently Arabspeaking
Christian
>> apparently. Huh. Hey Rob, you you you
probably don't know really know Arabic,
man. You just
>> Yeah. Sorry.
>> Either way, look, Rob and the exugesus
that he just showed us, etc., etc., etc.
Um, it does not mean that
it's the but this is just a side topic.
This is extreme side topic that we've
dealt on for like half an hour or so.
>> It's not a side topic. It's the It's the
topic. I'm pro. Well, I'm trying to show
you something. So, so you would you
would never tell a woman who's married
to suckle physically like to put her
nipple in another man's mouth who's not
her husband?
>> I I already answered that and I told you
that I would tell her to breastfeed him
through a medium. Absolutely.
>> Right. So, you wouldn't tell her to put
her breast in his mouth.
>> Uh, which is which the hadith does not
show. Exactly. Yes.
>> Well, the hadith does, but I just I'm
just asking just to get your clear
position. You would not tell her to put
her breast in another man's mouth. Is
that right? which is not what the
prophet did. Yes, that's right.
>> I didn't just answer the question if you
can, please, brother.
>> I answered it.
>> No, you didn't. You're just saying it's
not what Muhammad did. I didn't know my
answer. This is live. People can see my
answer.
>> Yeah, people. This is live. So, would
you or would you not see my answer?
>> Tell a woman to put her breast in the
mouth of another man. Yes or no?
>> And this is someone who did not say
that.
>> Would you do it or not?
>> Um, Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
didn't do it, so I would have done.
>> Rob, is my question hard?
I don't know, man. This is tough.
>> Rob, would you ever Hold on. Rob, would
you ever tell a woman to put her breast
in the in the mouth of another man who's
not her husband?
>> No. If I would be the seal of all the
prophets and the best example for
mankind, as they say, I would never do
that. On top of that, um we know also uh
here comes the disaster. I have a source
where Muhammad gave the permission to
herself, Isisha, his baby bride, to
suckle the grown-up men. So, no, of
course not. A normal human being who's
not a uh a the youth as they call him,
you know, a youth, someone who is not a
cockled, he would not do that.
>> Okay. So, if that's the case,
>> they call him a youth, by the way. I'm
sorry, I'm using the Arabic term.
>> You see how you see how easy Rob
answered the question for me. So Ali,
would you yes or no? Would you tell a
woman to put her breast in the mouth of
another man? Yes or no who's not her
husband?
>> If I was to tell that I'm basically I'm
basically going off the false premise, a
false premise that we've just said. So
based on based on external exogesis of
someone say saying that it has to be
directly uh consumed from the breast,
not not through the medium as in
breastfed. Would you would you do what I
asked or not? Would you tell her to put
her breast in the mouth of another man?
Yes or no? Bro, it's simple. Yes or no?
>> For the sake of moving on with this and
because I've given enough evidence. Yes.
Uh no.
>> No, you will.
>> Okay. Muhammad in this case
>> according to you with a very perverted
interpretation from a hadith which you
do not
>> I just read it. I'm going
to call scholars perverted.
>> Yes. At least he's acknowled
>> a perverted interpretation of of the
actual word. But what I'm saying is
there's al from a hadith that basically
is used a hadith chain of narration to
uh authenticate the the the correct from
wrong which you do not have an
equivalent for to authenticate that your
gospels which were written in uh 60 AD
80 AD 100 AD um that they were
transmitted to us with the same chain
that you guys used to pick on the
hadith.
>> Okay brother so let's go ahead and move
on. you wanted uh to bring up the uh
Allah having a son thing.
>> Yeah, I wanted to bring it up but
because I want to be more closer to your
topic that you're talking about
morality. You mentioned that prophet
Muhammad benefited from prophethood and
you mentioned how many wives etc.
>> Specifically, please man, we got to we
got to be focused, bro. You said bring
up.
>> So, do you want the son or do you want
me to address the morality thing?
>> I want you to address Allah having a son
because that's what you said you wanted
to talk about.
>> Yeah. So basically it says um you said
that
how can he have a son when he does not
have a uh a friend a mate. Exactly. So
um the thing is that uh the the the term
used here
it's not saying how
does not mean how it does.
>> Come on man.
>> And I'm giving you I can give you an
example from the Quran that says no. How
are you going to tell me when this is
from the Quran? Like for example, when
the Quran says,
is using it for when to describe when
will they be stopped?
How are you guys being bewitched? And
then this verse that you're saying says
it's ridiculing the prospect of Allah
having a partner which has caused a lot
of these problems for you. When you say
is Jesus the most high God or is he not
the most high God etc. This is all
because of a power vacuum of associating
a partner with God the father the
greatest according to you guys Jesus
saying the father is greater than I.
This is a problem that you guys
>> What does this have to do? This has
nothing to do please don't deflect. Stay
focused please.
>> Okay. Yeah. So so um so yeah you're
saying that God you're saying that our
argument is God cannot have a son.
That's not true. We are not saying God
cannot have a son or that he's saying he
cannot have a son without
>> I never said you said that. I'm saying
the the hadith or the Quran says that.
>> Okay, you're right. You didn't. But the
thing is that uh the verse you're saying
that you know they're trying to say that
he can't have a son without having a
mate. That's not correct. That's not
what that Quran says. And I told you I I
gave you evidence of being used to
describe.
>> You didn't give any evidence. Does it
Does it say how here? Does it say how
here in the Arabic?
>> Uh no. Um, look, the thing is I can't
tell you Arabic and you show me English.
I I gave you another example from Arabic
that describes
>> this. This is a corpus, my brother. My
brother, this is a corpus. It's an
Arabic corpus. So, what it does is is
that it breaks down each word in the
verse word for word. Okay? Phrase for
phrase. So when it says here we get down
to the part in 6101 to the how can he
have a sona yukunu
wadun right
>> okay yeah so
>> how can he have a son when he doesn't
have a mate
>> actually it's girlfriend the word is
girlfriend
>> I told you
>> means girlfriend
>> that's right okay Avery I told you that
this is ridiculing the prospect of God
having a partner in power which has
caused a huge I'm with
Brother, you don't have to you do not
brother, you do not have to break that
down to me. I'm granting you that that
Allah does not have a companion or
somebody equal to him in power. That's
not my argument. In order for him to
have a son, he would need a female a
female companion, right?
>> Uh no. So basically there's another
Quran verse that that that debunks this
kapuli. It says if Allah wanted to have
a son, he he would have chosen from what
he created. So he would have begotten a
son. The same way you guys believe God
the son is begotten by God the father.
The Quran verse says
he would have chosen from what he
created what he wanted. So this is so
this is so it's either these are the two
options you have. either your Quran two
verses are contradicting each other when
one says that Allah can have a son if he
wanted to and just choose from his
creation
>> and the other one says he can't have a
son unless he has a girlfriend or you
can reconcile the two and put them
together harmonize them when it says
that that Allah can't have a son I'm
sorry if he if he wanted to have a son
he could choose from any of his creation
he would just need a female uh mate to
do it with
>> um I I have a question to Ali Ali I have
a question if you don't Excuse me, Rob.
Rob, look. Excuse me. I want to respond
to Avery with all due respect to you. I
mean, you were brought in to talk about
a hadith and you did your job. Thank
you. But I am here to speak to uh speak
to Avery about this. Look, so so let me
let me talk to him oneonone on this one.
I I asked you about the hadith in the
Arabic. Let me talk to him oneonone on
this one.
>> Sure.
>> So So Avery, I I I told you and I pulled
up verses from the Quran again, such as
etc. And I'm telling you that these are
described these are being used as where
and when. It's not just so how.
>> Okay, look look look look ask any Arabic
person now what is the Arabic word for
how they will not tell you. They're not
going to tell you and if they tell you
just laugh at them because what it says
the Arabic word for how is ka.
>> Let me go.
>> This doesn't the word Anna work for how?
Um to be honest with you, look I'm not
extremely I'm not extremely but I know
enough to say that look to say I to say
like I told you does simp does does mean
where and when in other verses from the
Quran that I'm telling you about that I
know also mean how
>> I've memorized
>> does it also mean how
>> how is how is ka how
>> so the word so just to be clear the word
ana does not also mean how
>> uh the word for how for me is is
>> for you
>> okay for
I got you. For you.
>> When I when I pull up the corpus, does
it also demonstrate that the word Anna
could be used for how?
>> There's that possibility. Yes.
>> Okay. So, according to Arabic language,
the word Anna can also be used for how.
It's not excluding the word how. So,
when it uses is in this verse, it's
using it it to mean how. How can he have
a son when he doesn't have a girlfriend?
That's what the verse says, bro. That's
correct. But it's also it's doing that
to to ridicule the idea of sharing that
he has a companion, right?
>> Yes. And there's another verse that says
>> so it's not the only way. It's not
limiting.
>> It is. Let me tell you how. Okay. So if
I were to say, how can I drive the car
when I don't have the keys? According to
that statement, what do I need to drive
the car?
>> A key.
>> Exactly. Right. If I said if I said how
can I plant the tree when I don't have
land according to the statement what do
I need to plant the tree
>> the the the thing you said but so I get
the argument sorry
>> yeah so one last example just one last
example I'll let you I'll let you touch
on it okay
>> if I were to say
>> how can I have a how can I have a son
when I don't have a mate
>> according to my statement what do I need
in order to have a son
>> a mate
>> so according to what Allah says says,
according to his statement, how can he
have a son when he doesn't have a female
girlfriend? Right. A girlfriend. That
means he needs a girlfriend in order to
have a son. That's just what he's
saying. It's a limitation. No, you're
correct. I mean, that is that is like
I'm not going to dispute that.
>> But I'm saying that God is in here. He's
trying to ridicule having a partner,
period, a mate, a son, etc., etc. So,
saying it's ridiculing the idea of God
having a mate anyway. It's ridiculing
it. So,
Oh son. So it's just the thing to and
then the other verse the other verse
that I told you that says if he wanted
to have a son he would have chosen from
what he wants from what he created.
>> So so he could have
so he could he could have a son if he
wanted to. However, in light of the
other verse if he wanted to have a son
he would need a girlfriend to have a son
with. That's that's how you put those
two verses together or else they
contradict. One verse is saying that
Allah could have a son if he wanted to.
The other verse is saying he needs a
girlfriend to have a son with. So it's
either those work together or you're or
you're putting them against each other.
>> Again, like I told you, like I told you
does not just mean how and this is like
it's not a definite we already got
or you just admitted it
>> and it's also in chapter 340. It's the
same
which means here's Zechariah in context
in chapter 3:40 he uses the and he says
my lord how can I have a son when I'm
old and the same means how there so what
do you mean so so so basically it's to
ridicule the idea of god having a
partner wife girlfriend son either or
it's ridiculing this idea and the other
verse that says if he wanted he would
have begotten the same way you believe
that Jesus peace be upon him was
begotten and by the father. Uh it says
that. So I just wanted to correct that
there that
>> you conceded to what I said earlier,
bro.
>> Yeah.
>> This is I'm I'm not conceding. I'm just
respecting my I'm respecting my own
limited intellect on the full depth of
the Arabic language which all three of
us are actually guilty of. We're not.
I'm just respecting that. So I'm leaving
this I'm not saying that I am the
authority for Arabic or whatever. That's
all I'm doing. However, when it comes to
limiting God, etc. I mean limiting God
would be to associate certain things
with him. For example, saying this
cannot forgive us.
>> Yeah. Before you keep going, this is the
this is why this is a problem because
this limits Allah, which means he's not
the true God. Because he cannot have a
son of him of his own self, but he needs
help outside of himself to have a son
with. That demonstrates he's not truly
God. He's limited. Okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Can I respond to that? Look,
I I'll say this cuz we we've been
talking a long time. I do got to let the
other guests come up, but you can come
back up. It sounds like you want to talk
about the deity of Christ next time. So,
when I have that topic, you can
definitely come up. We can talk about
Jesus being God and and all that. Okay.
>> Okay. But after I say this last thing,
please. Yeah.
>> Sure. So when it comes to limiting God,
uh basically the idea that God had to
accept the blood money to forgive
original sin and our sin, et
I'm I'm giving you the courtesy of
giving you the just really quick.
>> I was about to give you the courtesy of
getting the last word, but you take
advantage of that by by slandering my
religion.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah. So if you're going to sing if
you're if you're going to get a last
word,
>> don't don't misrepresent my religion or
or else this this won't this won't end
well. So what what is what do you have
to say on 6101? What's your last
statement for that?
>> 6101. So basically I wanted
>> because we because we spent all the time
speaking about two different two things
that I did that I did not come here to
speak about and I didn't get a chance to
speak about what I did want to speak
about.
>> You said you wanted to correct me on how
can Allah have a son. So brother I but I
have to move on. So I'm giving you the
courtesy like literally 30 seconds
I want to explain to you the link what
we just said.
>> I want to explain the link to you. The
link here is limiting God.
>> The link link.
>> Okay.
>> The link between what I'm saying
limiting God.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> You understand? So can I move on or is
that going to upset you? Can I say what?
>> Yeah. No. So if you don't I mean
>> if you don't have anything to say about
what I just said about 6101 then I got
to move on bro
>> because you're saying about limiting
God. I do want to say something about
limiting God which is like you know very
cool in
>> Bring that next time. I'm I'm literally
about to I'm about to move on. Bring
bring that next time.
>> No problem. I understand that. I'll
bring it up next time. Next time I come
on.
>> All right. All right. Take care, man.
Thanks for coming through.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Brother God Logic, if you allow me to
say something about what was being
discussed earlier.
>> Yeah. Um he just said if you call Allah
father you are limiting God. If you
claim that Allah has a son you're
limiting God. Well he just admitted that
caiff Omar one of the famous companions
just limited Allah and he became a kafir
because I have here an authentic hadith
from a book in front of me where Omar
calls Allah father because he says that
Allah has children. So that means can we
do can we find a Muslim who will say
Omar was a mushik a and limiting Allah
for calling him a